the College of psychologists a bunch of
people put in power by the government
basically is threatening to take my
Dad's psychology license because he's
been criticizing the government this
isn't a joke this has been torturing my
family since 2018. seriously bullying my
dad in a way that really caused everyone
in my family a lot of stress I think
it's part of what contributed to him
being quite ill in 2019-2020 colleges
are in charge of doctors massage
therapists dentists they've been around
since about the 60s and it turns out
which I guess isn't that surprising
they've been infiltrated by the
government and now it looks like they're
being used to control particularly
conservative working professionals think
you can trust your doctor to talk to you
about anything that the government
doesn't back definitely not although we
probably already knew that this is kind
of how colleges work in part so this is
how bad it is he's getting investigated
because of tweets he's tweeted personal
tweets opinions things he said on Joe
Rogan this such a scam too they're
requiring him to do media retraining
that he pays 225 dollars an hour for for
an unspecified amount of time and then
at the end of that training they decide
whether or not he's learned anything and
whether he can continue being a
psychologist this isn't even a process
that goes to court it's just this
regulatory board of like 12 tyrannical
individuals it's crazy that what you say
online can be used to get rid of your
license if people don't like you
politically which doesn't sound very
Democratic to me they don't like his
opinions so they're trying to shut him
down but right now it's in a very real
way the tweets they've identified as
problematic include the Tweet about
Elliott page dad's trying to protect
kids from being sterilized that's
definitely not appropriate the Tweet
about the obese woman on Sports
Illustrated again obesity should not be
celebrated it kills people and then
tweets criticizing Justin Trudeau and
another member of the liberal party
threatening to take your job as a
serious threat anybody can submit a
complaint about a psychologist or a
doctor for that matter anybody doesn't
have to be a former client so for Dad
it's random people on Twitter
complaining about him out of his
audience of 20 million he has 12
complaints the college could throw these
complaints out but instead they're
threatening him and have been for years
wasting his time bullying him and
threatening to take his license maybe
we'll do a podcast about it I'm not
entirely sure what to do here other than
tell people about what's going on but
maybe complaining back at them is
appropriate you can go to the link I'm
going to link it below and you can enter
in a complaint about the college itself
and the people running it because
they're bullying and harassing my family
so I don't know where the protection
there is where's the protection against
a tyrannical organization that's set in
place to protect the government this is
basically the Communist Union at this
point picking on a Professor for his
opinions on Twitter against the
government it's absurd if they end up
managing to take his license which will
really be hard on my dad you won't be
able to trust your doctor your lawyer
anybody in Canada if the government is
just controlling all working
professionals God forbid you tweet out
your opinion about the government you
might have your license taken away or be
subject to their 1984 media retraining
that you pay for oh my gosh on their
website it says anyone who has a concern
about a psychologist or psychological
associate can file a complaint or submit
a report this includes a client a family
member or friend of the client an
employer an insurer a colleague or a
general member of the public which is
definitely great for celebrities because
no one's going to go after them randomly
on Twitter you can't just complain about
the college you actually have to
complain about an individual but look at
here it shows who's running this scam
right on their website according to this
guy on Twitter
these are the people you can see it
right on their website running this
organization that's currently
threatening my dad even elon's responded
to Dad's tweet which was really a tweet
for help in all honesty because we're
not sure what to do here obviously he's
not going to be doing their media
retraining but this is pretty scary I
thought it was a good idea to make a
video to tell you what's going on it's a
serious War out there it's crazy and we
could use some help here he's tweeted
out the Ontario College of psychologists
has demanded that I submit myself to
mandatory Social Media communication
retraining with their experts among
other crimes retreating Pierre poliev
and criticizing Justin Trudeau and his
political allies this is real this is
actually happening I've been accused of
harming people although none of the
complainants involved in the current
action were clients of mine past or
present or even acquainted with any of
my clients I'm to take a course of such
training with reports documenting my
progress or face an in-person tribunal
and suspension of my right to operate as
a licensed clinical psychologist about a
dozen people from all over the world
submitted complaints about my public
statements on Twitter and Rogan over a
four year period out of the 15 million
who follow me on social media claiming
that I had harmed not those people just
harmed people with his views and then
here they are you can go to college of
psychologists of Ontario there's the
council and the professional members
feel free to submit complaints about
them ridiculous I guess we'll see if my
dad continues to be a clinical
psychologist